E aí
[Música]
G1
E aí
e eu tô nervoso
eu tô nervoso porque os excelentes
oradores que tiveram que antes estrearam
este ideias nós dizemos a nossa relação
com Alcobaça e eu que tinha que ter uma
toque sobre improvise não prepara essa
parte e vou ter que improvisar e isso é
uma deixar nervoso mas eu vou tentar a
verdade a minha relação com o que passa
é
eu sou de Alcobaça pronto a Eu não
acreditei ser pessoa cá eu não moro numa
Terrinha perto de Alcobaça não estou
literalmente de Alcobaça agora 15 ligado
que esta cidade tem é que curiosamente
maior parte das pessoas que me fizeram a
pergunta que eu mais vezes assim na vida
eram daqui Qual era a pergunta João não
te sentes mal por ter desperdiçado tanto
tempo da tua vida ajudar música para
agora estás a fazer outra coisa qualquer
e eu gostei muito sincero eu nunca sei
que aqui responder
E por que essa pergunta tá então para lá
daquilo que eu considero Lógico que
dizer só não não chega
repare a única razão pela qual eu estou
aqui hoje foi porque eu passei 9 anos da
minha vida ajudar música vezes nós vamos
seis a estudar Jazz EA arte de
improvisar e foi por conseguir aplicar
os princípios de improvisação áreas como
empreendedorismo e educação que eu estou
neste palco porque eu tenho essa ideia
que nós nascemos com um potencial
inato enorme para poder improvisar Mas
eu posso provar isso basta levar a vossa
infância
e como vocês eram crianças espero que
nesse crianças à espera também tenho
brincado nunca me deixou a pé de vocês
isso olha tens aqui um livro com todas
as brincadeiras pode fazer Escolhe um e
brincar
eu não posso inventávamos as
brincadeiras mesmo dentro das histórias
nós inventávamos estarmos improvisavam
as histórias e as brincadeiras o quintal
da minha avó foi a final da Champions
foi uma trincheira de guerra foi uma
galáxia distante no futuro da humanidade
estava em jogo
o e nunca ninguém me disse olha tem
desde brincar a isso nós simplesmente
desenvolvemos essa capacidade de
improvisar Store só depois a vida começa
a passar e nós perdemos essa qualidade o
que se perguntam nenhum acho que isso é
um desserviço que nós fazemos a
sociedade porque deixar de partilhar
convosco uma teoria eu acredito que nós
na vida Estamos numa três situações
primeira as coisas correm exatamente
como nós queremos Acordamos e olhamos
para o nosso dia pensamos como é que
temos que ele corra e tal corre
exatamente como Pensamos a mim nunca me
acontece não sei se calhar a vocês
acontece para mim dizer o que leva a
segunda situação que as coisas correm
mais ou menos que nós queremos que vocês
Nos levantamos olhamos para o dia e
assim não corre muito distante daquilo
estamos a espera não temos que fazer
grandes imprevistos mas não é bem igual
aquele também ao que estávamos em e é
mais frequente Mas eu acredito que
terceiro e pode ser que ela é mais
frequente em nosso dia a dia que nós
acordamos e olhamos para o nosso dia por
como estávamos que as coisas
acontecessem e depois a vida Acontece
Ah e alguém que se esqueça não sei o que
ir no trabalho a parte do para do
PowerPoint não funciona e na tags alguém
que se esquece de mudar o
não é e nesse momento quando isso
acontece quando a vida Acontece o nosso
plano vai a vida e nós temos que fazer
alguma coisa que o realidade temos a
frente e que nós fazemos
E improvisamos
agora se vocês puderem neste ideia e
utilizarem como um par de óculos para
olhar para você vida você não precisa
passar um maior parte do vosso tempo
improvisar e ainda assim nunca ninguém
chegou ao pede-se ao pé de vocês e vice
isso Olha vou te ensinar os princípios
da improvisação tem um objetivo hoje é
esse é conseguir. Um aumentar a vossa
consciência para o fato de passarmos
grande parte da vida a improvisar é o
mesmo tentarmos um pequeno Museu que
talvez permita a improvisar melhor nos
vossos contexto no dia a dia ok e por
isso vamos pegar naquilo outros são os
elementos de um bom sol Ok está durante
muito tempo já se e já vivi no improviso
e a primeira coisa que nós precisamos
para criar um bom sono de Jadson bom sal
de música são os acordos mas agora são
basicamente a base da música é sobre
eles que nós vamos improvisar a nossa
melodia para cada acorde existe aquilo
que somos escalas escalas são é
basicamente a sequência de notas que
cabe dentro de um acordo tanto Aquelas
que nós podemos utilizar e para criar o
nosso sol para improvisar e por último
temos a melodia que é um dia é
basicamente a forma com Nós escolhemos
organizar aquela sequência de notas
porque é isso que é o único F cada
pessoa vai organizar as notas de uma
forma que expressa aquilo que está
sentindo naquele momento aquilo que nós
nos já se chamamos de improvisação
Alerta cúmplice composição espontânea
naquele momento que eu estou a sentir o
que que eu quero ficar até plantas são
mais ou menos os elementos por um bom
solo na música curiosamente são mais ou
menos parecidos com os elementos para
improvisar uns bem na vida tudo começa
com aquilo que eu chamo o contexto e
contestam as situações importantes OK
são aquelas situações da vossa vida onde
você pode acontecer que tem um impacto
positivo ou o impacto negativo das
coisas que realmente importa coisas como
a apresentação que vocês vão ter que
fazer e que vai ditar a vossa nota na
escola coisas como uma reunião que vai
definir o futuro da vossa empresa e com
pedirem o vosso Amado a vossa amada em
casamento e seus contextos segunda coisa
que vocês precisam é dos componentes e
os componentes é o que são um conjunto
de ações possíveis nesse contexto eu vou
fazer a apresentação comporte ou sem
porque eu vou fazer aquela reunião
importante vestido de camisa ou vestido
calções eu vou pedir a minha amada em
casamento de joelhos ou tentar Ok todo o
conjunto de coisas possíveis naquele
contexto isso tudo correr bem eu vou
partir desse fazer São pessoas que tem
alguma lógica e que se prepararam bem
por um contexto que é importante isso
tudo correr bem corrido como o plano e
você não tem nem improvisar
o
caso isso não aconteça E caso a vida
aconteça então vocês têm terceira fase
que eu posso plantação que basicamente a
forma com vocês pegam e todas os
componentes em todas as ações possíveis
escolhe organizá-las forma que consigam
ter um resultado melhor deixa Melhor
exemplo fácil para vocês perceberem esta
pirâmide a primeira vez que eu dei um
curso de formação profissional foi o
curso de inteligência emocional e era um
curso de dois dias com 30 pessoas que eu
nunca tinha conhecido e e lembra-me que
eu passei horas e horas e horas a
estudar ok ele e tudo que era livros
sobre inteligência emocional eu vi
vídeos eu fiz cursos tudo isso que é o
dia da formação pessoas entram e começa
a formação corre tudo muito bem a meio
da manhã eu digo o pessoal pediu fazer
uma pausa de 10 minutos a e na pós as
pessoas saíram de saúde e vou olhar para
uma grande perdi o planeamento e percebi
que na primeira metade da manhã eu tinha
dado a matéria de todas do dia
há 10 minutos de intervalo né portanto
foi um minuto panikkar e nova improvisar
o que é que eu fiz eu conheci o contexto
contestar a inteligência emocional e eu
também conhecer os componentes que eram
todos os dados e informações informações
que eu tinha adquirido sobre
inteligência emocional no percurso de
preparação para aquela formação eu fiz
eu fiz foi em 9 minutos eu rabisquei uma
série de Jogos por coisas muito simples
mesmo a quase de criança para fazer com
este gerente de empresas e tal
o primeiro acabou vamos próximo dia e no
final da formação Eu diferente e parte
OK pergunta que fala que foi o momento
que estarão mais e toda a gente
respondeu os jovens que eu tinha
improvisado
é a única razão pela qual eu consegui
naquele momento aquelas pessoas
gostassem da formação foi porque Eu
reconheci isto aliás essa foi foi o
principalmente que eu percebi o que fere
os princípios de improvisação que eu
aprendi na música são válidos também
para a minha vida
o ok então este é o modelo que eu quero
que eu quero passar para vocês não
coisas são teus contexto importante
perceber coisa que são os componentes
desses mesmos contexto e reparem vocês
não tem que treinar um improviso para
tudo vocês não tem medo de treinar o que
é que vão gritar a pessoa que não põe
pisca e passava as esquerda tá bem não é
preciso mas daqueles que realmente podem
ter um impacto forte na vossa vida
nesses contextos então convém que vocês
se preparem agora para vocês pois
temperaturas de fusão de duas regras as
regras do Improviso primeira o
imprevisto disso
e Como assim Não por isso tudo estamos é
paradoxal mas a única forma que o músico
já se tem de saber que Improvisa sobre
qualquer acordo é conhecido qualquer
escala e Vocês não conhecem escalas sob
um sistema instrumento musical você não
conhece as escalas e improvisar mas
esquecer que elas ajudar a
e isso é muito importante que às vezes
as pessoas acham que às vezes uma
capacidade muito desenrascar não eu sei
me desenrascar porque eu preparo-me para
desenrascar eu preparo para que naquele
momen se for preciso improvisar tudo bem
Está repente não apresentação Power
Point não há problemas em faz se
estresse mas por quê Porque passo
bastante tempo a estudar uma improviso
para os nossos contexto para as pessoas
que realmente importam vi quem tempo
para preparar as várias opções de quem
tempo a estudar os vossos componentes e
segunda regra do improviso esta não lute
contra a realidade
e
Como assim estou de cá já faz um dia de
caso vocês vão ver que estão a meio do
vosso sol e o pênis vai fazer um corte
mas eu não tou a espera ou o baterista
vai fazer um filme qualquer na bateria
que não era o ritmo de vocês queriam e é
muito fácil você ficar nem da vossa
cabeça a dizer coisas como mas não era
isso que eu precisava não era isso que
eu queria pedir que ele tem que ficar
aquilo curiosamente são mais ou menos as
mesmas coisas que nós dizemos para nós
próprios quando a vida acontece né tipo
também porque é que o meu patrão disse
isto mas porque é que a minha mulher
disse aquilo mas porque é que o meu
miúdo tempo de fazer isto Mas porquê mas
porquê mas porque
quanto mais tempo nós passamos a lutar
contra a realidade
em menos tempo passamos improvisar com a
realidade porque não vale a pena vocês
podem revelar o quiserem a partir do
momento em que uma coisa aconteceu
aconteceu não dá a gente pode ir para as
mesmas não vai usar então quanto mais
depressa do Conselho de aceitar a
realidade mais pressa pode improvisar
uma solução por cima dela ok portanto
modelo Aonde vocês têm identifique os
contextos podem os componentes tem a voz
plantação primeira regra um imprevisto
segunda regra não luzes com a realidade
e eu eu vou terminar com uma situação
deste senhor que eu posso em fazer parte
do grupo chamados a mãe nunca fã que eu
tenho uma frase que eu gosto muito de
que o improviso é algo bom demais para
se deixar ao caso e eu concordo Eu acho
que já que vamos passar maior parte da
nossa vida a improvisar então que o
façamos bem e de uma forma que contribui
para um mundo melhor para nós e para
aqueles que nos rodeiam é obrigado a
E aí
Oi e para terminar a equipa da t-rex
aliás Vamos mandar uma mega salva de
palmas para a equipa da Telex por favor
porque eles merecem
é um trabalho excepcional com trabalho
sensacional e basicamente eles que eles
pediram para fazer uma coisa que era
improvisar uma música assim de repente
para provar que eu sou uma pessoa que
prática aquilo que defende a e portanto
eu vou agarrar na minha guitarra mas
antes de agarrar eu acho que a gente
essas notas dó ré mi fá sol lá si dó e a
pedir que alguém dissesse uma nota
qualquer da obrigado a gente fica maior
ou menor
o maior até fiz obrigado
E aí
o
pior em
E aí
[Música]
G1
E aí aqui ó
E aí
G1